hello time then for the press preview
it's a first look at what is on the
front pages it's time to check out the
headlines with the political editors of
the daily mirror and the sun pippa
carrera and harry cole a very good
evening to both of you this bank holiday
speak in a moment first of all though
let's check out those front pages
nowhere is safe is the harrowing
headline for the eye which reports on
what it calls a major escalation of the
russian offensive in ukraine
according to the times the ukrainian
president says this means that the next
phase of the war has begun
the mirror looks ahead to boris
johnson's appearance in parliament
tomorrow to face questions over his fine
for party gates what it calls johnson's
walk of shame
the sun leads with the awful story
tonight the death of the newborn son of
footballer cristiano ronaldo and his
partner georgina rodriguez just so
tragic
the guardian understands that phones in
boris johnson's downing street office
have been infiltrated by hacking
software that turns them into remote
listening devices
and in fact that's also the lead stories
you can see in the mail
now according to the telegraph ministers
have been told they must order their
civil servants to stop working from home
and return to the office full-time
the metro here is that a million
discounted train tickets will go on sale
tomorrow in an effort to encourage rail
travel now that those covered
restrictions have been relaxed
the express says the queen is set to
invite harry and megan to appear with
her on the balcony of buckingham palace
during her diamond jubilee to try and
heal the rift in the family
and the financial times reports that the
private equity group which co-owns the
supermarket chain asda has now valued
its stake in the company 20 times what
it paid just a year ago
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen join the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us and i'm joined tonight by pippa
carrera and harry cole great to see you
both this bank holiday monday thank you
for joining us and pippa why don't we
crack off crack on with the start uh
with the front page of the eye
nowhere is safe which is just awful
isn't it the fact that we've seen these
missile attacks now in la viv which has
been relatively and i say relatively
unscathed it's been a place where many
people fleeing from the east have sought
refuge
yes jonathan it's been that one of the
main routes out of the country for the
millions of people that have fled the
war they've gone to la viv and then over
into poland and beyond and it's where
we've seen many western television
correspondents presumably also sky
amongst them reporting from relative
safety though often in the background of
those reports we've heard um air
aircraft
sirens going off in warnings to or
missile attack warnings to
the population but it has remained
relatively safe and it's only really
just this attack in the last 24 hours
uh which i think has killed seven people
that suddenly sort of unsettled all
those people in levitive and has really
been a sort of real marker of russian
russia's escalation
of the conflict again we obviously in
the last couple of weeks and sort of a
de-escalation as russian russia troops
pulled um out of keeve and the
surrounding areas but the but uh all the
sort of western intelligence suggests
that uh we we were anticipating
a re-escalation primarily in the east in
the donbass region and certainly
eventually seems to be saying that that
has now happened and uh you know russian
forces are are pounding uh cities in the
east and attempting to take that that's
those territories once and for all
uh someone calling harry uh with a with
a scoop a late night scoop perhaps um uh
but let's look at uh your article in the
sun harry because we know uh president
zielinski saying tonight that the
russians have begun their offensive to
take control of eastern ukraine the don
bass it's been anticipated now for for
some time the president saying it is
underway and what you've said in your
piece in tomorrow's paper is that boris
johnson is sending more missile aid
yes so the all eyes now sort of turning
to the to the east of ukraine that uh
zolensky saying the war for donbass has
begun sort of uh that sort of sporadic
spray of of missiles all over um all
over um ukraine over the weekend perhaps
signaling a new phase of the war but um
the the aggression focus really in the
east tonight and we'll remain see what
happened overnight but this week
hopefully not too late the latest
tranche of um
of weaponry is going over from uh from
from the west to the uk leading the
charge on that including um
sorry my phone is now ringing again um
including uh some quite quite serious
kit these stormers these stormer
um uh missile transporters which i tell
you what harry don't worry just take a
pause and turn it on to silent don't
worry we've got time i'm trying hard
these are 50 mile an hour armored
armored vehicle um other vehicles can
carry 17 um start uh star strike
missiles which are the very aggressive
anti-chopper anti-aircraft missiles
which um uh blizzalensky's uh um foreign
ministers saw on a visit uh sorry
defense minister saw in his visit to
salisbury plain two weeks ago has
requested we send them and i can tell
you tonight that britain has agreed and
they are probably quite soon on their
way to ukraine okay that's very
interesting because as our correspondent
uh was saying
from ukraine this evening it looks like
the next phase of this war is going to
be quite different it's going to be less
suburban it's going to take place in
in a much wider landscape which could
mean different types of weaponry are
required okay let's move on from ukraine
pepper turn to your paper front page
johnson's
walk of shame he has got a big day
tomorrow
yes so as you will all remember boris
johnson uh received his first fine uh we
are expecting there to be more but we'll
have to wait and see for some of those
lockdown breaches
um the part of the parties and social
problems that happened in number 10. and
he became the first prime minister to be
found guilty of breaking the law sitting
prime minister to be found in breach of
the law at that point but of course all
the mps were often their constituencies
and um number 10 has been packing the
prime minister's diary with everything
from a trip to kiev to um to a new
asylum policy announced by pretty patel
at the end of the end of last week so
this is the first opportunity the mps
are going to get to question the prime
minister directly and indeed his first
opportunity to address them and we're
told that tomorrow in the comments he's
going to make a statement in which he
will again wholeheartedly apologize for
breaching the law although there seems
to be some suggestion that he will then
go into some detail
to explain why in fact he didn't believe
it was breached at the time some might
view that's contradictory but there you
go
and then he will try and sort of move on
the narrative and focus on some of the
other issues which have been dominating
government
clearly the prime minister wants to get
back on the front foot with this he's
very conscious the mps will be talking
to people in their constituencies and
while there is sort of a be this feeling
among some of the pm's closest allies
that that you know he's safe and that he
that partygate is behind him having
spoken to lots of conservative mps
including some ministers today it's
quite clear that they're not quite so
convinced that there's still big
question mark over the prime minister's
future and that there's there's
potentially bumpy roads ahead with both
uh possibly more fines the run-up to the
local elections a a red wall
um a regional by-election on the horizon
and the prime minister's going to have
to do a lot of convincing them
um that he is in fact uh you know the
right person at the right time to carry
on timing i was on his side there's not
an obvious an obvious successor that's
on his side as well but it's but it's
anything but straightforward the prime
minister and the next couple of days
going to be important to him
okay well we've lost harry maybe his
broadband company was giving him a call
to say there are a few issues but pippa
thank you for the moment that will try
and regain that contact with him
meanwhile civil servants are apparently
being told they need to stop working
from home is that fair enough we'll
ponder that in a couple months
hello again welcome back to the press
preview still trying to reconnect with
harry but pippa is with us pippa front
page of the guardian this is an
incredible story isn't it it's it's
another hacking story of sorts uh this
time using this pegasus spyware tell us
about it
so
there's a canadian group based in a
canadian university which have um
uncovered that pegasus spyware has been
used uh right across and that they're
not just concentrated on britain but
this story is about britain right across
british government including it um in
departments like the foreign office
whereas there's a lot of sensitive
information around and number ten which
of course is home to the prime minister
and the uh the
the device basically um it means that
they can take a mobile phone like a
normal mobile phone like any of us have
here and they can use it as a listening
device so sensitive conversations are
going on between the prime minister and
aides potentially um or between security
officials um even more worryingly then
they by accessing some of the phones of
those individuals they would be able to
listen in and the suggestion is that
this that they pinpointed um this group
have pinpointed the origins of this of
this hacking to the uae which of the
season is an ally of of britain and will
inevitably raise questions for
um you know for for that relationship
and i'm sure that there will be they've
been questions asked tonight by the
foreign office of their counterparts in
the uae um to try and determine what's
going on there obviously at a time when
security is heightened globally anyway
and in particular
russia has a record of using ransomware
and other cyber attacks
as a sort of hostile force to
against its enemies then the last thing
we want is any sort of breach in our
security um so i'm sure that you know
it's going to ring alarm bells at the
national cyber security center and
they're going to be getting the
officials to try and look into this um
as as fast as they can to try and close
some of those security breaches
yeah really concerning you can read more
about that in tuesday's guardian now
there's good news and bad news for uh
commuters as we uh once again start
heading back to work after the easter
holidays um front page of the telegraph
uh pippa
stop home working the civil service is
to be told that ministers ordered to get
staff back into offices now what i mean
one of the one of the very few
benefits of the pandemic has been that
actually the the the revelation that you
can work from home and do it
successfully um has been opened up to
many of us um and yet the civil service
have been told they all have to come
back full stop
yeah this has become a real bug bear of
the government hasn't it this sort of
demand that the white hole civil
services are back at their civil
servants are back at their deaths and
it's not one actually which is
replicated in the private sector um i
mean you speak to people across the city
for example and as you rightly say
jonathan one of the benefits that they
have that sort of city chiefs have
recognized of the pandemic is that
ability for if not working for him the
whole time and certainly sort of
flexible working so days when maybe
staff need to get stuck into data or um
you know do some reading or some writing
and don't necessarily need many
face-to-face meetings although of course
as we all know those can be done on zoom
um that is uh you know that's actually a
benefit to their businesses and staff
are more productive the days of thinking
of presenteeism or thinking that staff
aren't there seem in the private sector
to be gone but as the telegraph um story
shows uh this is the drive by jacob
rees-mogg to get more civil servants
back at their desk this is not an
attitude that seems to be shared in
government at the moment it's kind of
part of this wider picture of um this
split if you like between uh politicians
and civil service that just been in
place ever since dominic cummings the
pm's former top aide came in and decided
that he wanted to rip up the civil
service and that you know they weren't
effective they were holding ministers
back and so on now it may be bloated in
some parts but i think you know my
experience of white hill civil servants
is certainly that they are you know top
of their game and they do it for the
love certainly not the money um but
there are some examples in this story of
some departments where really a very low
number of staff are coming in on any
given day department for education only
about a quarter same for dwp whereas
other departments like um department of
health and department of trade
are much higher but he quarters the
staff are in on any given day but it
doesn't look part of a gradual shift
back to sort of more normal life
okay sorry people have to cut in because
we're running out of time and i just
want to show the front of the metro uh
the good news for commuters uh if you're
getting a train uh tomorrow half price
rail fares are on the way or certainly
one million tickets to be reduced this
spring so a little bit of uh easter
cheer pippa thank you very much indeed
we'll try and get hold of harry uh for
the next preview in half an hour's time
right now quick look at the weather